[MUSIC PLAYING]
Markers-- they're much
more useful than just
for showing a location on a map.
Actually, they can be
used to visually convey
information about a location.
I'm Ankur Kotwal,
and together we're
going to look at ways to
visualize locations on a map.
Let's say a user is searching
for a well-rated restaurant.
They'd fire up your app
and see that there's
a bunch of restaurants
in their vicinity.
But it's not always easy to tell
which ones are worth visiting.
To see the ratings
for each place,
they may end up having to
tap each one first and see
the rating.
Marker selection and
animations can be a great way
to show this information.
In this example, markers
that lack color rate poorly.
And the vibrant,
colorful markers
are the highly rated ones.
There's also animated steam
on some of these markers,
helping to highlight the
best rated restaurants.
To achieve this animation,
we're changing the marker icon
by calling setIcon periodically.
To desaturate the
marker icons, we're
also using a
ColorMatrix ColorFilter
from the Android framework.
First, we set up the ColorFilter
based on the rating scale.
And then we apply the
filter to the marker image.
Now, markers are great for
showing points on a map,
but sometimes you can
just have too many.
In this case, we have too
many well-rated restaurants
around us.
It's a nice problem to
have, but it's not helping
our user choose a restaurant.
And in such situations, you
need to display many markers,
but still keep the
view comprehensible.
So we're going to look at two
ways to overcome these issues.
The first is through the
use of marker clustering.
As the zoom levels
of the map change,
you can aggregate markers,
making for a much more
digestible view.
Now, a zoomed out view shows
us how many restaurants
are in the surrounding areas.
You might be looking
at this effect
and wondering that well, it
looks like a lot of work.
Well, let me put you at ease.
It's a four-step process.
Step one, add the library
to your gradle config.
Step two, add the
GetLocation override
to your main data class.
Step three, instantiate
the ClusterManager
and register it for a
couple of map listeners.
And finally, step four, replace
your marker management code
with calls to the
ClusterManager.
It will manage adding and
removing the markers for you.
Seriously, that's
it, four steps.
You can optionally
customize it further
by providing custom
aggregate markers too.
Let's look at the second method
to show marker aggregation.
I reckon it looks really cool.
Heat maps.
Here, we're replacing a count
of markers with a heat map
to show the concentration
of these markers.
How cool does that look?
Achieving this effect
is also just four steps.
One, add the library.
Two, instantiate a
HeatMapTileProvider.
Three, pass it your LatLngs.
And four, use it to
create a map overlay.
That's it.
You can optionally
customize this further
by specifying the gradient and
the radius of the heat map,
too.
So just remember,
information overload
is a common problem
with mobile apps.
Location apps in particular
suffer from poor user
experiences when dealing with
lots and lots of information.
Markers, clustering,
and heat maps
offer beautiful
visualizations, enabling
you to build amazing maps.
The Android Maps
utils library provides
easy to use implementations for
marker clustering, heat maps,
and even more.
So be sure to check
it out right here.
I'm Ankur Kotwal,
and I look forward
to seeing your amazing maps.
[MUSIC PLAYING]